As we saw in lesson one,
Android makes it really easy to create
UIs that stretch based on screen size.
We call these fluid layouts
because they can stretch and
compress depending on
the amount of space they have.
And you can build these using layouts
like linear layout, grid layout,
frame layout, or relative layout.
But fluid layouts only get you so far.
Most of the time, on larger screens
you can end up with a lot more white
space than you originally planned for.
These massive seas of white space
result in an unbalanced UI and
can make your app look less useful and
less beautiful.
Now before we jump into
ways to improve this,
let's dive a little bit further
into the problem at hand.